ils sont devenu éleveur de chèvres
apiculteurs ou fabricants d'huile
ils ont tout quitté pour changer de vie
et s'installer à la campagne
les néo ruraux comme on les appelle sont
ils des aventuriers contemporain
pourquoi bhl t-il la vie alors que de
nombreux ruraux font le chemin inverse
direction les paysages du berry où
chaque année ils sont plusieurs
centaines à poser leurs valises
[Musique]
elle s'occupait de gestion immobilière
et lui était salariée dans une grosse
entreprise à narbonne il y a cinq ans
emilie et james ont quitté le soleil
pour faire du crottin de chavignol prat
de sancerre
[Musique]
mais trente ans j'ai repris le chemin de
l'école on a repris l'année d'école pour
faire un passé un diplôme agricole dont
qui s'appelle le brevet professionnel
d'exploitations agricoles noté le seul
couple et les plus vieux mais bon ça
nous a permis de nous entraider ne st
pas aussi notre jeune couple voulait
travailler avec des animaux
il a fallu tout apprendre
c'est peut-être fargo l'âge je te laisse
un moulage et moi je vais faire de
salage
on a fait pas mal de stages ou a permis
de vraiment travailler par nous même des
gens qui nous ont vraiment laissé faire
faire nos erreurs chez eux et puis fin
je me dis pas qu'on a passé des avoirs
chez nous mais au moins de voir un petit
peu ce qu'il fallait faire et ce qu'il
ne fallait pas faire un chemin semé
d'embûches mais pour eux l'essentiel est
ailleurs
vous savez cette petite angoisse que
vous avez au quotidien d'aller
travailler pour un patron donc ça se
passe bien ou mal un peu importe s'était
pas enfin pour mon cas c'était cela se
passait très bien
vous avez pu cette petite angoisse
quotidienne du dimanche soir à vous dire
de moi je reprends le boulot le matin
quand je me lève
voilà bon on met quoi un petit quart
d'heure à se préparer on traverse à
court et puis malet les chefs tous les
jours elles ont sourire il faut plus les
jours de oliver et ça pour moi ça pas de
prix
[Musique]
aujourd'hui emilie et james eux possède
150 chèvres etc hectares de terre ils
ont investi 400 mille euros dans leur
ferme et gagne un peu plus d'un smic à 2
le plus difficile a été d'emprunter on a
eu cinq refus dans la région centre
pendant sur le cher et après on qu'on a
dû aller voir les banques avec donc
l'ancien locataire de la ferme plus
notre ami o chez qui on est et on était
logés pour essayer de convaincre de
notre projet dont ils nous ont aidés en
allant voir les banques en leur
expliquant bas que bas notre projet
tenait la route
c'est des personnes qui ont vraiment cru
en nous on avait une volonté de toute
façon vraiment qu'on a vraiment défendu
l'un et l'autre et voilà je veux dire
danse de ce côté là il faut vraiment on
s'est donné les moyens et voilà on a
bousculé certaines portes on a bousculé
la chambre d'agriculture on a bousculé
les banques on a bousculé la ddt et en
six mois on s'est installés les
premières années ils n'ont pas quitté
leur ferme et non pas non plus prêter
attention aux rumeurs je vous dirais que
c'est quelque chose que qu'on n'a pas
trop su on n'a pas voulu savoir donc
voilà
c'est pas mieux jusqu'à nos oreilles
pour autant emilie n'a pas de regret je
laisserai pas ma place à fait sûr
emilie et james vendent leurs fromages à
la ferme mais aussi sur les marchés via
des revendeurs
le temps ne passe plus de la même
manière qu'une passion passion et c'est
vraiment passionnant puisse un rêve pour
nous pour notre famille pour toulousains
pourtant les quatre maintenant puisqu'on
a deux enfants
chouette vidéo les voir travailler enfin
travailler entre guillemets mais de les
voir gambader dans nos pattes quand on
travaille fort avec nous il n'ya pas
meilleure récompense quoi
[Musique]
j'avais pareil
plus au sud du berry fabrice a quitté la
capitale avec femme et enfants pour le
village de saint gaultier dans l'indre
[Musique]
dans mon cas ça fait deux ans et demi
est arrivée ici
j'ai pas réussi à retourner à paris
alors que j'ai de la famille à paris
c'est la famille qui vient
j'ai pas encore réussi à y retourner son
occupation principale aujourd'hui c'est
courir les bois pour s'occuper de sa
vingtaine de ruches et sauvages
disséminées dans toute la campagne
[Musique]
j'suis papy culteurs encore je pense que
sa demande soit plus que deux ans c'est
aussi ça voilà c'est aussi l'intérêt
c'est s'engager je pense comme beaucoup
de gens qui peuvent partir la campagne
sur des métiers qu'on maîtrise pas qu'on
maîtrise pas au bout d'une saison sur
une saison d'études une saison
d'apprentissage ou pratiquer les bois et
les ruches un univers aux antipodes de
sa vie d'avant au début j'ai commencé
cotées en bourse
ensuite j'étais contrôleur de marché
après j'étais ce qui s'appelle brokers
courtiers aux négociateurs à la bourre
sonné
voilà ce court est plus après les
opportunités professionnelles
j'avais moins de motivation
professionnellement pourquoi pourquoi
est-ce que c'était pas la ville qui nous
démotive est je pense que j'avais envie
de changer de métier
voilà
sont pas contents
en début de printemps vont se nourrir
dans les ailes et de l'aubépine il ya
ces l'aise en fait ça va être pissenlit
les aubépines
les epide aubépines
une fois la récolte effectuée
c'est un autre travail qui commence
je fais miel mon mon but c'est pas de le
vendre en vrac dans des fûts c'est de le
revendre au détail donc j'ai été obligé
j'étais obligé de faire un site internet
un site marchand
j'essaie de me rendre le produit le
produit est naturellement bon ça c'est
pas mal j'ai de la chance j'ai rien j'ai
rien ajouter rien à faire il est bon
après faut le rendre beau
[Musique]
je comprends pas
j'ai presque un rôle social
de 45 m² à paris fabrice est passé à 200
mètres carrés avec jardin et dépendances
pour stocker sa récolte annuelle une
tonnes l'an dernier
alors j'ai mis des étiquettes
ça correspond aux différents lieux dits
ou sohu sans mes ruches et et je suis
content quand je sais qu'il y avait
jamais eu de rush là par exemple j'en
tiens j'ai trouvé ce petit ce petit coin
de paradis pour elle qu à l'air de
fonctionner donc ouais ça fait plaisir
j'ai immigré de la ville à la campagne
je transit dans la vie je fais mon
voyage dans la vie je deviens rural a
[Musique]
émigré de la ville à la campagne
une aventure qu'on choisit de livre
annie et joachim eux aussi ont quitté
paris pour le berry plus précisément
pour le moulin de paix seul hier une
huilerie du xviiie siècle pour laquelle
ils ont eu le coup de foudre
[Musique]
côté quand même deux trois ans pour
vraiment apprendre comment faire une
bonne mine
c'est pas très compliqué les étapes sont
assez faciles mais ce qui faut il ya
beaucoup d'attention et quand on a une
phase en à poil il faut il faut y être
tout en fait
d'ailleurs je dois y aller pour ne pas
aggraver la pâte
la pièce exhale le parfum des noix et
des noisettes
[Musique]
c'est un plaisir de faire quelque chose
de de ses mains c'est vrai que c'est
important
à présent c'est pas c'était pas trop ce
que j'ai fait bien que la production
soit plus tôt ce soit plutôt sous la
responsabilité de joachim et ben c'est
faire en fait quelque chose de 2 à
jusqu'à jusqu'à z le travail manuel n'a
pas effrayé un ex-cadre dans un
organisme international
enfin moi personnellement tout cas
j'avais l'impression que je pouvais
faire une expérience de vie ici que je
que je n'avais encore jamais fait
voilà donc c'était tellement différent
de ce que j'avais pu vais vivre jusqu
alors que j'étais très très tenté de le
faire et de le faire avec mon mari
les habitants des alentours amènent
leurs récoltes et il aime bien repartir
avec leur huile le doublon et de noix
c'est pour faire l'achat de 8 2 mois
une grande fidélité de plus le temps
aussi de rester un peu au moulin de
parler d'eux on a le temps de parler aux
gens ce qui n'est pas le cas je pense à
paris volent de crépon deviner
au moulin il ya une clientèle qui s'est
formé depuis des générations en fait
donc qui habitent ici et c sont des gens
qui sont des agriculteurs c'est s'aider
des bourgeois c'est des aristocrates
aussi donc on a si je peux dire tout une
carotte pour parler comme un géologue
d'une société couach et toutes les
strates de de la population au delà
d'assurer la pérennité de la production
d'huile
le couple vend aussi les produits du
terroir et contribue donc à redynamiser
le village
c'est essentiel est essentielle parce
qu'ils apportent notre regard aussi mais
je pense que vend les générations
évolué dans les derniers mentalités et
il me semble que maintenant il ya un
fait il ya un brassage qui fait que les
gens qui viennent d'ailleurs y compris
hors d'eux hors de france
sont mieux acceptés compris intégré mais
il faut aussi simple
celui qui arrive il faut aussi qu'ils
s'investissent
s'investir oui mais en acceptant
quelques sacrifices
c'est vrai qu'on s'a mais tout à fait
qu'on n'allait pas devenir riche mais
qu'on allait avoir la possibilité de
vivre dans un lieu qu'on aime avec
d'autres facilités voilà mais ce n'était
pas le but non plus le but c'est de
vivre est de faire quelque chose qui qui
qui méritent d'être faits
non
partir pour changer de vie ils ont tous
osé le faire mais s'il ne regrettent pas
leur choix
c'est sans doute parce qu'il s'inscrit
dans une démarche mûrement réfléchie
presque une mission qui leur permet de
revenir à d'autres valeurs
[Musique]